[Musica]
ciao a tutti
allora sono molto agitata questo mi
sembra evidente
infatti partiremo così insomma quando mi
hanno detto che sarei stata su questo
palco
il primo pensiero che ho avuto non
appena messo giù il telefono coi ragazzi
è stato non sono in grado
ed è un pensiero che mi capita spesso di
avere quando
non lo so c'è qualcosa al di fuori
dell'ordinario quando ho tempo magari un
risultato per qualcosa per il quale ho
lavorato il primo pensiero
è sempre lo stesso che non sono in grado
vorrei dirvi che non mi condiziona e
invece mi condiziona e come
vorrei essere una di quelle persone che
sa benissimo cosa come iniziare il
processo creativo che si diciamo se
andrà a creare quello che verrà esibito
e invece per me non è così per me ogni
processo creativo personale inizia con
una lotta
una lotta che nemmeno io so quanto dura
diciamo quanto basta per riuscire a
portare a casa la vittoria perché perché
gli dico con una parte mia personale una
parte che sta dentro di me
detto così una parte molto tossica alla
quale tempo fa
diversi anni fa ho lasciato il completo
controllo della della mia vita
e diciamo che litighiamo per un po
cercando di capire se io sono veramente
in grado di riuscire ad affrontare il
compito che mi è stato assegnato
dura 12 settimane anche di più a volte
fino a che
diciamo prende il sopravvento la mia
parte sana e mi rendo conto di potercela
fare il mio è mio psicoterapeuta qui
sono molto affezionato aglo cito sempre
marco direbbe che questo è altro che uno
strascico della malattia di cui ho
sofferto di anoressia nervosa un
disturbo alimentare
di questo offerto per circa quattro anni
che mi aveva quasi uccisa
non so se voi vi siete mai odiati così
tanto da provare via fare il morire di
fame
io l'ho fatto e il disturbo alimentare
per me era una falsa amica
era qualcosa che
una risposta sbagliata a una domanda che
io avevo dentro di me
chi sono
vado bene sono giusta
e in qualche modo il disturbo alimentare
riusciva a a darmi quel quella sorta di
di sicurezza di controllo sugli
avvenimenti circostanti
è per questo che poi mi arrabbio quando
si parla di disturbo alimentare si pensa
all estetica no perché non è così e ben
più profondo
è una sorta di coperta verso il mondo
esterno
nella mia testa se io ero perfetta e non
intendo solo fisicamente intendo dentro
come vi pongo quelle persone sul lavoro
non sarebbe potuto accadere niente cioè
se io sono perfetta figurati se esistono
gli imprevisti
se io sono perfetta niente potrà farmi
del male
chiaramente non era così
in qualche modo è stata anche un po type
la società no tu sei quello che guarda
tu sei il tuo lavoro e io non mi sentivo
mai di aver raggiunto dei risultati
abbastanza soddisfacenti da sentirmi
parte del mondo parte di qualcosa
in qualche modo i numeri
qualsiasi cosa era giudicabile
attraverso i numeri per me il talento le
persone
il mondo circostante
credevo solo lo specchio credevo solo a
quello che potevano vedere i miei occhi
se io ho un dato un nero su bianco e
quello quello il valore di una cosa
quello che tutti possiamo vedere
e ovviamente questo è un
è una cosa che non che non porta a
nessun tipo di risposta c'è il mio
disturbi limentare era una risposta
scorretta una domanda e una risposta non
arrivava mai
perché non ero mai abbastanza
e dato che il disturbo alimentare come
diciamo
disturbo mentale
in realtà
avevo l'illusione che stando insieme a
questa cosa non fossi mai sola che fosse
magari quella vocina che mi dicesse no
guarda che devi andata asta parte ma
secondo me non sembrava fare questo vai
a fare quell'altro ed era un modo
probabilmente per non sentirmi mai sola
sarebbe per me è impossibile
riuscire a descrivere il dolore che
accompagna una rinascita
che ha subito per quello pensa a una
rinascita penso sia una cosa
meravigliosa
non lo è
ma pure del in questo dolore in questa
morte in un certo senso di una parte di
ma con iniziato a stare bene
vi ho trovato tantissima vita
quando hai che fare con con la morte o
heavy di un'esperienza legata magari non
direttamente a qualcosa a qualcuno che
conosci la realtà cambia completamente
e in questo sordo impulso di morte che è
stata per me è l'anoressia perché è
veramente un rumore sordo
ho trovato il modo di amare a contatto
con me stessa
c'è un film che conoscete sicuramente
tutti
che io se dovessi dire viva beh ti devo
spiegare disturbo alimentare di gli
direi di andare a vedere il cigno nero
no conoscete tutti e penso che sia una
rappresentazione stupenda e artistica di
come un la dietrologia di un disturbo
alimentare ea un certo punto del film
senza fare grossi spoiler
l'insegnante di danza della protagonista
ne dice una cosa che mi ha veramente
colpito mi colpisce anche oggi
le dice
l'unico ostacolo al tuo successo sei tu
liberati da te stessa le dice no e io
dicevo ma che vuol dire
anche se devo essere un'altra persona
invece ho capito in un certo senso mi
piace
vederlo come come ricordano un po di
quello che ho passato io
questo questo impulso di morte mi ha
permesso di toccare la mia vera essenza
le mie fragilità cioè io sono così senza
a giudicarmi perché io questo lo dico
sempre non ho avuto scelta cioè io se
volevo sopravvivere dovevo mettere tutte
le carte in tavola dovevo mettere tutto
in discussione
cosa che poi ho capito che dovremmo fare
tutti prima o poi nella vita solo che io
l'ho fatto prima ma perché non avevo
scelta non sarei qui in questo momento
è
e questo
diciamo questo
questo toccare questo questa mia vera
essenza mi ha permesso di vedermi
davvero per quella che era e non per il
responso distorto che mi dava la mia
mente perché mi dà una risposta
completamente distorta in quei momenti
mi sono accorta di come as di che potere
immenso alla nostra mente su di noi di
come capace di distorcere completamente
un punto di vista solo per andare a
giustificare un un giudizio negativo
in quei momenti mi è capitato di dire
non ha più niente da perdere bene cambio
paio di occhiali ne metto un altro
vedo il mondo sotto lenti che magari non
avrei mai considerato prima e se vi è
capitato se lo state facendo adesso se
non l'avete mai fatto fatelo
perché vedete vi accorgerete che una
cosa che vi agitava ieri oggi è un altro
completamente diverso significato
e per me
diciamo questo
come posso dire mi in un certo senso
anche quando parlo con quei ragazzi
delle scuole io parlo con le scuole i
ragazzi per fargli capire non o disturbo
alimentare provare una maniera diversa
come sto provando a farlo capire voi
quando
spiego agli alunni il disturbo
alimentare di solito anche per togliere
un po lo stigma no che abbiamo sulla
salute mentale
io dico sempre che dovete immaginarvi in
un pensiero
normale perché tutti abbiamo leggono
tutti abbiamo quella vocina cattiva
chiamiamola così sopra le righe è
semplicemente l'estremizzazione di
questa cucina una cosa normale quando lo
dico vedo che tutti mi guardano così
come per dire no perché è difficile
entrare in un punto di vista di una
persona che era giornata in un altro
modo e per me questo è importante lo
faccio anche attraverso quello che
scrivono quando mi chiedono di che
scrivi perché io scrivo scrivo di questo
io cerco sempre in modo di trasmettere
ai lettori questo ti accompagno magari
del mio inferno personale ma non voglio
che tu chiudi il libro pensi a me a
opera cioè il mio il mio intento è
quello di trasmettere quello che ho
imparato in questa esperienza forte ad
altre persone in modo che possono farlo
anche loro e non è obbligatorio aver
sofferto di disturbi alimentari o di
qualsiasi altra cosa perché come dicevo
prima arriva un momento in cui bisogna
liberarsi da se stessi di vedersi per
quello che si è veramente
e
io non non posso dire di di amarmi
perché non è così
assolutamente
però mi voglio bene e mi rispetto molto
e chiaramente quando ti rispetti tutto
attorno a te cambia la percezione del
mondo occhiali già attorno cambia
completamente
praticamente non sei più disposto ad
accettare qualcosa o qualcuno qualsiasi
cosa che
sì al di fuori
del tuo delle tue consapevolezza del tuo
punto di vista tutti conosce talmente
tanto ormai dopo che come posso dire
selezionato le tue fragilità che dice ma
questo mi va bene ma e questo mi va bene
io non voglio fare questo voglio andare
lì
e questo è e non può più perdere tempo
tra l'altro per me che ho perso quattro
anni sono stati tanti io non ho più
voglia di perdere tempo perché il tempo
scorre veloce una cosa che ci tengo a
dire in conclusione di tutto quanto che
ci sarebbero alta 1 milione di cose da
dire un quarto d'ora è troppo poco
abbiate empatia non solo per gli altri
ma anche per voi stessi perché
sono nel momento in cui tu in patiti
contest st rendiconti accetti chi sei
davvero riesce a vedere anche l'altro
quello che passa l'altro il dolore
dell'altro e qui penso che questa sia
veramente una magia una cosa stupenda e
il mio consiglio
nel mio piccolo è quello veramente di
andate a scoprire chi siete perché è un
viaggio molto
particolare doloroso a tratti ma
stupendo liberatevi davvero da da voi
stessi da l'influenza no che può dare la
società di adesso che possono dare le
altre persone i giudizi tutto quanto
permettetevi davvero di di essere chi
siete perché insomma la la vita è vero
che breve e non c'è tanto tempo e penso
che sia stupendo riuscire a
incanalare i propri talenti davvero è
scoprirlo è sempre meglio scoprirlo
prima che scoprirlo verso la fine
e ogni volta nel mio caso io quello che
scrivo dico sempre sono morta tantissime
volte e ogni volta che ritorna in una
fragilità e l'esamino per bene in un
certo senso un paio di nuovo no sono
piccole morti piccole morti che che ci
sono sempre in forza di passarci
attraverso
si imparerà in un certo senso spero a
morire di gioia grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]